Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
Devo rompere il ghiaccio.
E che cosa può fare una professoressa,
per rompere il ghiaccio,
se non un'interrogazione?
Avete paura?
No, vabbè, per questa volta
lascio correre.
Però voglio rompere il ghiaccio
facendo un mini-sondaggio
per conoscervi, e per conoscere me.
Chi ama la matematica alzi la mano.
Sono quasi a casa.
Chi andava bene in matematica, ai tempi?
Eh, un po' meno.
Chi pensa che il talento
matematico sia innato?
Va bene, ne terrò presente.
Adesso ho conosciuto voi, mi presento.
Io penso che la matematica
sia il fondamento
di una società giusta, equa e democratica.
Per questo motivo,
ho riformulato questa bellissima frase
del premio Nobel, di Malala,
e l'ho riformulata così:
"Un bambino, una bambina,
un insegnante, un libro,
una penna e la matematica
possono cambiare il mondo".
Chi è d'accordo con me
di aggiungere la matematica?
Oh mamma, diminuiscono, bene.
Eh sì, diminuiscono.
Mi capita spesso di vedere questa cosa.
Perché?
Perché a ognuno di voi
sarà venuto in mente:
"Oddio, cosa c'entra
la matematica con la giustizia?
A me veniva il mal di pancia, quando
avevo il compito di matematica.
Non dormivo la notte per prepararmi".
Bene: io ho scelto, invece,
di studiare matematica
e di fare l'insegnante di matematica
perché per me era fondamentale
dare gli strumenti critici e culturali
agli studenti e alle studentesse
per cambiare questo mondo,
per cambiarlo in meglio.
E la matematica risulta
essere fondamentale.
Quello che voglio fare con voi, oggi,
è farvi capire e portarvi
in questo mio percorso,
quindi farvi vedere che collegamento c'è
tra matematica, giustizia ed equità.
Ho bisogno però che siate con me,
cercando di andare oltre l'orizzonte
e capire che c'è bisogno
di una visione diversa della matematica
e quindi di un modello diverso
della matematica.
Lo farò, o perlomeno cercherò di farlo,
seguendo un ragionamento
di tipo matematico.
Cosa fa per prima cosa la matematica?
Fa un'analisi della situazione,
E l'analisi della situazione qual'è?
Andiamo a vedere che cos'è la matematica.
Non lo voglio fare con le mie parole:
sarebbe troppo semplice,
e potreste dirmi: "Non è così".
Lo faccio con alcune frasi
scritte da mie ex studentesse,
e miei ex studenti,
quando hanno finito il liceo.
E quindi possiamo vedere che cosa?
Chiara, che oggi fa
l'ultimo anno di medicina,
mi scrisse questo:
"Grazie per avermi
fatto vedere la matematica
non solo come un insieme di formule,
ma come un modo di affrontare la vita
semplificandola grazie
al ragionamento e alla fantasia".
La quinta I,
quella che i miei colleghi dicevano
"una classe di disperati",
sbagliando,
perché persone che, vedrete,
in grado di scrivere questo
non mancano di speranza,
anzi ne hanno molta,
è questa.
"Grazie per averci regalato la libertà
e per averci insegnato
a ragionare e a vivere".
L'ultima è Bianca.
Bianca fa l'ultimo anno di Fisica,
e mi ha scritto questo:
"Grazie per avermi dato occhi
per cercare nuove terre".
E a questo punto io, quando
mi sono trovata queste frasi,
ho detto: io,
con le mie ore di matematica,
i miei integrali, le mie cose,
ho fatto questo?
Bene, allora loro mi hanno indicato
la strada di andare oltre, ancora oltre
e pensare di cambiare
questo metodo d'insegnamento.
Ma la matematica, perché?
La matematica è, come hanno detto
i miei studenti e le mie studentesse,
libertà e forza liberante.
Che cosa hanno scritto loro?
Questo, è uno strumento potente
che ci permette di essere
quello che noi vogliamo essere,
oltre stereotipi e pregiudizi.
Guardate, questo loro hanno scritto:
vivere, la matematica è vita,
è un modo di semplificare la vita.
Ma perché lo è? Chi ce lo dice?
Ce lo dice Daniel Kahneman.
Daniel Kahneman è uno psicologo,
premio Nobel nel 2002 di economia.
Lui si è occupato
di teoria delle decisioni.
Se voi ci pensate,
in ogni momento noi decidiamo.
Una statistica ci dice che, in un giorno,
noi decidiamo 35.000 volte.
E siamo sicuri che quelle decisioni
siano solo nostre,
o non siano condizionate?
Voi oggi avete deciso di venire qui.
Se non foste venuti qui, probabilmente
non sareste quelli che sarete
quando uscirete da qui.
Quindi questo è fondamentale.
Ma queste decisioni, come le prendiamo?
La maggior parte delle decisioni,
ci dice Daniel Kahneman,
sono prese in base a quello
che lui definisce il "Sistema uno".
Che è un sistema veloce,
agisce velocemente;
ma è stereotipato,
e si basa soprattutto
sulle emozioni e sui ricordi,
quello che ci dice la pancia.
Ma la decisione così -
siamo sicuri che le strategie
che noi prendiamo
e le decisioni che prendiamo
con questo sistema uno
siano le nostre, e non siano
frutto di stereotipi?
Vi faccio vedere
uno stereotipo semplicissimo:
se voi incontrate un uomo - dico un uomo
perché con una donna sarebbe
ancora elevato al massimo,
e avremmo una questione di genere
che non voglio mettere -
e chiedete a quest'uomo: "Che lavoro fai?"
E lui vi risponde:
"Faccio l'intellettuale".
Voi che cosa pensate che faccia?
La maggior parte delle persone
dice: "Il filosofo", "Uno scrittore" -
i miei studenti dicono: "Niente",
però, scherzi a parte, lasciamo questo.
Lui invece risponde: 'Sono un matematico,
e lavoro al Cern di Ginevra'.
Bene, eppure nessuno mai
risponde così. Perché?
Perché c'è lo stereotipo
che i matematici
e gli scienziati e così via
siano semplicemente dei tecnici,
e non facciano un lavoro
di tipo intellettuale.
Allora Daniel Kahneman ci dice
che se vogliamo decidere
in modo consapevole
si deve attivare quello
che lui chiama "Sistema Due".
Che è un sistema, come lui dice,
educato ed educabile, razionale, logico,
ma lento.
E quindi, se noi vogliamo
che le nostre decisioni siano solo nostre,
dobbiamo attivare
questo secondo sistema, allenarlo.
E farlo diventare in grado di controllare
se le soluzioni prese
dal sistema uno siano corrette.
Bene, questo sistema due
non è altro che, per me,
il pensiero matematico.
Cioè, davanti a un problema:
fare l'analisi dei dati;
capire quali sono quelli fondamentali
e quali sono quelli accessori;
impostare una strategia; verificarla;
se si sbaglia, reimpostarla
e arrivare diritti all'obiettivo.
Questo è il pensiero matematico,
e questo ci regala la libertà
che hanno detto i miei studenti,
quindi deve diventare veloce.
Bene, ma mi dite:
"Che c'entra, Lorella, la giustizia?"
E allora andiamo a vedere
che cos'è la giustizia.
Consideriamo Ulpiano:
Ulpiano è uno dei più grandi
giuristi romani,
se non il più grande giurista romano,
e lui ci dice che la giustizia è:
"La costante, perenne volontà
di dare a ciascuno
ciò che gli spetta di diritto".
Sen, filosofo ed economista indiano
che si occupa dei diritti civili,
che cosa ci dice?
"Il concetto di disuguaglianza
non consiste solo
nella disparità di reddito,
ma soprattutto nella disuguaglianza
di opportunità, di possibilità,
di scelta, di libertà individuale.
È fondamentale, per ogni individuo,
avere la libertà di decidere
come concepire se stesso"'.
Quindi, se uno Stato deve dare
a ciascuno e ciascuna
la libertà di diventare
quello che si vuole essere,
e le stesse opportunità,
vuol dire che un metodo matematico
deve portare la competenza
matematica a tutti e tutte.
Ecco che allora il modello
di insegnamento della matematica
si deve fondare, prima di tutto,
su quello - scusatemi sempre
il gergo matematico -
su quello che è un assioma fondamentale:
"Non uno, non una di meno,
nella matematica e nella vita".
Perché se anche lascio fuori
una sola persona,
dimentico una persona
e quindi lo Stato risulta essere
uno Stato non giusto e non equo.
Ma allora mi direte:
"Come fare, Lorella?
Qual è la seconda cosa?"
Dobbiamo andare - ricordiamoci sempre
quello che abbiamo detto all'inizio -
oltre l'orizzonte,
pensare qualcosa anche che non c'è.
Dobbiamo cambiare
la figura dell'insegnante,
e dell'insegnare matematica.
Quindi fare che cosa?
Fare un'altra cosa, secondo assioma:
"La matematica è per tutti e tutte".
Quindi non esistono -
per questo vi ho fatto alzare le mani -
non esistono persone non dotate;
esistono solo persone non allenate,
o persone condizionate dagli stereotipi.
Chi ce lo dice? Ce lo dice Carol Dweck:
Carol Dweck è una psicologa
cognitiva di Stanford,
il riferimento mondiale
della psicologia cognitiva e sociale.
Lei ci dice che sono solo
le condizioni familiari e scolastiche
che in qualche modo condizionano
lo sviluppo del talento.
Quindi, che cosa bisogna fare?
L'insegnante, ce lo dice sempre lei -
e dà un consiglio
a genitori e insegnanti,
che è questo:
fornite sempre situazioni sfidanti
ai vostri figli e figlie,
studenti e studentesse,
fate sì che si applichino.
E premiate l'impegno, non la performance,
perché è solo in situazioni sfidanti
che si sviluppa questo modo di procedere.
Perché se la matematica
è forma di pensiero,
è un modo di affrontare la vita,
io devo allenare il pensiero matematico
come [fossi] in palestra;
quindi devo far lavorare i miei muscoli,
devo sviluppare la capacità
di intuire, immaginare, progettare,
dedurre e controllare,
per poi misurare e quantificare
fenomeni e fatti della realtà.
Questa è la cosa importante.
Quindi situazioni sfidanti, perché?
Perché comunque,
l'errore non è un limite,
ma è un'opportunità.
Un'opportunità
di riflessione e di crescita.
Quindi voi avete visto
che matematica, giustizia ed equità
vanno di pari passo.
Ma allora resta un'ultima sfida
che vorrei riuscire a combattere con voi,
che è questa:
l'Italia, e molti paesi,
sono agli ultimi posti
dell'analfabetismo funzionale
per quanto riguarda la matematica;
quindi la matematica,
se il nostro è uno Stato giusto ed equo,
deve entrare in tutte le case.
Non solo nei ragazzi e nelle ragazze,
ma in tutti noi, in tutti gli adulti.
E questa è l'ultima nostra sfida,
ed è quella di far arrivare
la matematica ovunque.
Forse qualcuno starà pensando
che questa è utopia, non succederà mai,
e da matematica quale sono
dico che basta solo
trovare la strategia giusta.
Perché, come diceva
il grande Adriano Olivetti,
"Il termine utopia è la maniera più comoda
per liquidare quello che non si ha voglia,
capacità o coraggio di fare.
Un sogno è sempre un sogno,
fino a quando non si comincia
da qualche parte.
Solo allora diventa un proposito, cioè
qualcosa di infinitamente più grande".
E oggi, il sogno di Lorella
non può essere realizzato
se non grazie anche a voi.
E quindi, sogniamo insieme.
Grazie.
(Applausi)